Black Panther director Ryan Coogler
will be developing a new series
set in Wakanda on Disney+. Here are some
stories Black Panther fans want to see in it.
Vibranium is the miraculous metal with
sound-absorbing properties that is the basis
of both Wakanda's enormous wealth
and its technological wizardry.
It's one of the most powerful substances on
the planet. Almost all of it is in Wakanda,
and what little exists outside of it has
already been enough to change the world.
"Cap's shield is made out of Vibranium.
They made Vision's body out of it.
Black Panther's suit is made out of it."
The bulk of it crashed down to Earth in the form
of a meteorite ages ago. The local warriors,
led by a man named Bashenga, fearlessly
visited the site and discovered the
material's unique properties and
set about using it to make weapons.
However, the strong radiation from the
Vibranium mutated some of the tribesmen
into "Demon Spirits." Bashenga drew strength
from the Panther God and defeated these menaces,
and his strength and leadership united
all of the tribes and formed Wakanda.
Bashenga became the Black Panther, creating
a dynasty that would last through the ages.
Considering that all of the Black
Panther ancestors are accessible
through the trance-like communion
in the Heart-Shaped Herb ceremony,
there's an easy way to bring this
narrative into the modern day. Bashenga,
the discovery of Vibranium, and the founding
of Wakanda could be its own extended story arc.
“It was built on a mound of the most
valuable metal known to man. 'Isipho,'
they call it. The gift. Vibranium."
There is also an opportunity to
introduce a number of new characters and
expand on the origins of each of the tribes.
If Vibranium itself is the focus of the arc,
the story of how the Great Mound was sealed off,
protected, and mined over the years and how that
affected local politics and culture has a lot
of possibilities as well. The decision to hide
Wakanda's advanced nature from the rest of the
world is another potential story of its own.
"This never gets old."
M'Baku was one of the breakout
characters of the Black Panther movie.
The chieftain of the Jabari Tribe,
he challenges T'Challa for the kingship
of Wakanda in ritual combat and loses.
Living in the mountains, the Jabari
separated themselves from the other
tribes and were generally hostile.
However, M'Baku comes to T'Challa's aid
when Killmonger steals the throne and even
becomes a huge part of Wakanda's defense
when Thanos invades Earth. He also
has a pretty good sense of humor.
"One more word, and I will
feed you to my children."
"I am kidding, we are vegetarians."
In the comics, he is a much more sinister figure,
as he directly tries to usurp the throne and
betrays T'Challa's friendship. Then
he becomes a full-on supervillain,
taking on the power of the sacred White
Gorilla. However, he always keeps his
Jabari tribesmen in mind and protects them even
while he rejects the modernization of Wakanda.
"Witness the might of the Jabari, firsthand!"
One element from the comics that
could be fruitful for M'Baku's story
is the introduction of his
cousin, Chante Giovanni Brown,
a Jabari native who grew up in America. She dubbs
herself "Queen Divine Justice" and grows up as a
normal American teenager until she is summoned
home to become one of the new Dora Milaje.
This could all fit into M'Baku's story
after the events of Avengers: Infinity War.
Did he have a hand in ruling Wakanda in
T'Challa's absence? What role did the Jabari
have in the post-Thanos world? Fleshing out
the Jabari society and history as they adjust
to becoming a more active part of Wakanda
could be an entire story arc of its own.
T'Challa's father T'Chaka was the last Wakandan
king to hide how advanced the nation was from
the rest of the world. As advanced as
his anti-surveillance technology was,
even he had difficulty keeping out all invaders,
especially when betrayed by one of his
own. T'Chaka established a worldwide
network of Wakandan spies and operatives
and sent his brother N'Jobu to America.
Seeing racial injustice in America and beyond,
N'Jobu rejected Wakanda's noninterference policies
and worked with the mercenary Ulysses Klaue
to steal Vibranium. N'Jobu compromised the
existence of Wakanda in order to get what he
wanted, forcing T'Chaka's hand as he killed him.
T'Chaka leaving behind N'Jobu's son N'Jadaka,
aka Erik Killmonger, to be raised as an orphan
was a questionable moral decision. This raises
the question: What other tough decisions did
T'Chaka make during his reign? How did he
shape the Wakanda that T'Challa inherited?
"I am sure you did what is right for Wakanda.
You always do. You are a great king, Baba.
And that is why you will always reign."]
T'Chaka demonstrated that he was willing
to kill a member of his own family
in order to protect his country,
so who else did he have to kill,
especially as superheroes and villains started
appearing? How aware was T'Chaka of beings like
the Eternals? How much did he teach T'Challa as he
was growing up, and how much did he keep hidden?
What was his relationship with his wife, Queen
Ramonda , like? There could be a great deal
of backstory established for modern-day
Wakanda as T'Chaka's life is explored.
Nakia was introduced in Black Panther as a
spy and T'Challa's on-again, off-again lover.
"Hi."
This was a sharp break from the comics,
where Nakia was one of two Dora Milaje,
but her obsession with T'Challa eventually
warped into her becoming the deadly assassin
Malice. The Nakia of the MCU is a far nobler soul,
but they barely scratched the surface
of her character in the movie.
A story arc following Nakia's career
undercover would be fascinating,
starting with what led her to choose a career
that took her outside Wakanda so often.
Her desire to make a difference
in other countries by infiltrating
and destroying human trafficking rings,
for example, revealed her overall goals.
"I can't be happy knowing that there's
people out there who have nothing."
What other kinds of missions did she carry
out? The idea that she was especially keen
on protecting women and children worldwide is
a fascinating one because of her willingness
to put herself into compromising situations.
Another question to answer would be how and if
she had to make tough ethical decisions with
regard to perhaps pretending to be part of a
corrupt organization or assassinating its
leaders. Only the vaguest details of her
career have been revealed, and this could have
direct relevance to her current life in the MCU.
Revealing what happened to Nakia after Thanos
disappeared T'Challa and half of creation for
five years would make for a fascinating story
arc. Is she still advancing humanitarian
interests as part of a new Wakanda? Or have
hard times made her an ever harder person?
The story of the lovers Ayo and
Aneka was explored in detail
in the World of Wakanda series, and it
could easily be adapted for television.
Both were members of the Dora Milaje who found
themselves rebelling against the monarchy.
Aneka killed a village chief who was abusing
women, but killing him was still forbidden.
Aneka was sentenced to death. Ayo pleaded
to Queen Ramonda on Aneka's behalf,
and while Ramonda was sympathetic, she chose to
follow the law to its letter. Ayo freed Aneka,
and they stole high-tech Midnight Angels armor.
Fleeing the city, they helped Jabari
tribeswomen and started routing bandits
who were abusing women. Taking in these women,
they became their own self-styled Dora Milaje.
They made an alliance with the
Jabari and another breakaway group,
the People, even though their motives
seemed questionable. At the urging of Shuri,
they helped defeat the People's attempt
at overthrowing T'Challa. In response,
T'Challa declared Wakanda to be a democracy,
remaining king but only in a representative role.
In the wake of the power vacuum of T'Challa
being snapped from existence in the MCU,
this is a story that could be adapted even
more readily. A Wakanda without the strong
influence of T'Challa is one that could
lapse into abuse. Seeing a story where
justice and freedom butt up against regimented
traditions is one that would be deeply resonant,
and the love story between Ayo and Aneka
would add another dimension to Wakandan lore.
In the comics, the Hatut Zeraze,
also known as the "Dogs of War",
were the Wakandan secret police.
King T'Chaka used them extensively
to repel invaders and assassinate
political enemies across the globe.
They were led by Hunter, the "White Wolf,"
who wore armor similar to T'Challa's,
only all in white. The Hatut Zeraze wore
similar armor and carried heavy ordnance
as soldiers and assassins. Hunter was
T'Challa's adopted brother. King T'Chaka
found him as an infant after he was in a
plane crash and raised him as his own son.
Being Caucasian, Hunter wasn't fully
accepted by many other Wakandans,
and he grew up jealous of T'Challa. The Black
Panther exiled Hunter and the Hatut Zeraze when
he became king because he had no interest in using
an assassination squad. Hunter later went on to,
on separate occasions, both provide aid
to T'Challa, and attempt to kill him.
None of these characters have been introduced in
the MCU, but it's not much of a leap to introduce
them, given the movie T'Chaka's demonstrated
willingness to kill enemies of the state. Given
a destabilized Wakanda, introducing Hunter
and bringing him out of exile in an effort
to seize power and "bring order" could make
him a powerful villain in the Wakanda series.
Like all of the best villains, he sees
himself as a hero. Like his adopted father,
he sees himself as being someone who can
make hard decisions when no one else can.
One of the greatest villains of Christopher
Priest's run on Black Panther was the Reverend
Doctor Michael Ibn al-Hajj Achebe . A native
of Wakandan neighbor Ghudaza , he was a simple
farmer until rebels from another country came. He
nursed them back to health, but his wife fell in
love with their leader. They left Achebe for dead
and thirsting for vengeance. He made a deal with
the devil Mephisto , took bloody vengeance, and
then went to America and got an education at Yale.
Achebe had his eye on Wakanda and its resources
and manipulated politics to stoke a civil war
that forced refugees into Wakanda. He
manipulated T'Challa into going to America
and tried to take the crown, but T'Challa
severed Achebe's relationship with Mephisto and
beat him. Of course, Achebe became even more
unhinged, designing demented death traps
for the Panther and talking to a hand puppet
named Daki . Achebe's twisted sense of humor
and grandiose personality make him a perfect
foil to the cool, calculating Black Panther.
Like Hunter and the Hatut Zeraze, Achebe could
be a perfect villain in a destabilized Wakanda.
Without having to deal with T'Challa, he could
easily try to become a demented populist leader,
a twisted advisor to whoever's in power, a
cult leader, or any number of other roles.
The Panther Cult and the White Gorilla Cult
aren't the only religions in Wakanda. Indeed,
many of the tribes worshipped their own gods.
Sekhmet , the Lion God, was originally an
Egyptian deity who tried to establish a
presence in Wakanda. Unlike the Panther
God, who only appeared to his priests,
the Lion God freely appeared before humans.
However, her violent nature didn't exactly
make her a popular candidate for worship.
She even attacked T'Challa directly in an
attempt to gain the Panther God's
secrets, but she was defeated.
The Panther Cult was created
by the Egyptian goddess Bast.
Other gods, such as Sobek the Crocodile
God, also had their followers in Wakanda.
This history of clashing gods could all inspire
a mystical and magical arc on the Wakanda show,
as various sects new and old challenge the
Panther Cult for control of the soul of Wakanda.
Even if it's in the background, the show
should certainly explore the many religions
represented in this rich and
expansive fictional world.
In the comics, Wakanda and Atlantis went from
having a tense coexistence to outright war. King
T'Chaka allied himself briefly with Prince Namor
the Sub-Mariner in a battle against the Nazis,
although he still kept Wakanda a
secret from the rest of the world.
T'Chaka knew Namor was a loose cannon and kept an
eye on him. When T'Challa became king, he nearly
got into a war with Atlantis over a territory
that both claimed, but cooler heads prevailed.
Later, in a conflict between
the Avengers and X-Men,
Namor turned against his old teammates
and tracked them to Wakanda. He used his
temporary Phoenix-force powers to wipe out much of
Wakanda. Later, when Shuri was queen of Wakanda,
she retaliated by destroying Atlantis. Namor
got revenge by setting Thanos on Wakanda,
telling him that the Wakandans held an
Infinity Stone. Things simply went too far.
Namor and Atlantis have yet to be introduced
in the MCU. The Black Panther franchise would
be a great launching point. There's even what
one might consider an allusion to Atlantis in
Avengers: Endgame, when Okoye refers to
an underwater earthquake near Wakanda.
"Do we have a visual? How
are we handling it?" "Nat.
It's an earthquake under the ocean.
We handle it by not handling it."
Namor would make a powerful anti-hero in the MCU,
being a generally noble figure who has good
reason to be angry at the surface world,
easily turning from antagonist to hero
over the course of a single storyline.
T'Challa's mother Queen Ramonda was a somewhat
underserved character in Black Panther.
She was there to see her son named as
king and then traveled to the land of
the Jabari in an effort to heal him. The
Wakanda series could go into much greater
depth regarding her character. How tuned in
was she regarding the activities of her husband
T'Chaka? Did she approve of him killing his
brother in order to preserve Wakandan secrets?
More interesting than that is what Ramonda did
when both T'Challa and Shuri disappeared for
five years. Okoye took her place as one of the
Avengers, but what role did Ramonda play in this?
Was she the default monarch of Wakanda? Did
she have to fend off attempts at the crown?
Seeing her having to deal
with the Hatut Zeraze, Achebe,
Prince Namor, and other threats could reveal a
heretofore-unseen killer instinct in Ramonda.
The show could also spotlight her own
agency as a queen. What was she like
growing up? How did she meet T'Chaka, and when
did they marry? What did she do before that?
How does she see Wakanda expanding
in the future? All these questions,
and more, are on the table for the
upcoming Wakanda series on Disney+.
"And, action!" "Wakanda forever!" "Wakanda
forever." "Wakanda forever, we're still rolling!"
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.